welcome back to the Ingram angle we
continue our discussion with three very
special women angel moms Michelle root
Maureen Maloney and Sabine Durden all of
them have lost family members sons to
illegal immigrant crime forever
separated from them Sabine you said the
killer by the way of your son how long
in jail 35 days 35 days 35 whole days
his mother was probably crying real hard
Paul Begala said this today about the
Trump meeting with all of you let's
watch he knows what he's doing he's
taking this raw real pain with these
poor families are suffering which is
authentic and he's politicizing it right
it is monstrous to take these folks pain
and then to try to use it to divide
America Michelle I don't even know how
to respond to that but that is so angry
because our voices need to be heard our
children's voices need to be heard we
need to hear the other side their
daughters beautiful beautiful very angry
very angry
Warren you know it's it's ridiculous
I was speaking out against this long
before Trump announced he was even
running to be President our children's
need to have a voice and we tried trying
to raise raise awareness and educate
people and prevent future deaths this is
Kathy Griffin Sabine so-called comedian
hmm message to the parents who are
onstage with Trump at this press
conference I am so sorry for your loss
but the man you're standing with Trump
could give two s she can't tweet without
swearing he's using you for propaganda
Sabine what do you have to say to Kathy
Griffin today I want her to meet me face
to face and tell me how this is publican
propaganda this is my son's ashes in
here he's the only man that brought this
to the forefront she needs to go into
stage somewhere in a little back alley
and entertain the two people that are
still following her she has no she just
has no crown she has no soul she has no
heart and I pray to God she never
this feeling Michelle a Salvadoran man
was telling a very heartfelt story an
illegal immigrant who was separated
crossing the border let's watch our
novus and his daughter were arrested in
Texas by border agents I was told my
daughter and I had to get on different
buses because there was enough room he
says but when they were driven to
McAllen where many migrants are being
processed
six-year-old Maybelline was suddenly
nowhere to be seen
don't let that me as I said where's my
daughter don't separate us don't let us
in but don't rip us apart
he says emotional yuria I was ripped
apart from Sara and you're accountable
for your actions you're the one that
cost that border illegally with your
child you were not looking out for your
child I concur with with with Michelle
we didn't have a choice our children
were ripped from our lives they have a
choice when women across the country
have a heart for all victims of crime
including these women